STEPHANIE WONG:
Hi, I'm Stephanie
and today I'll show
you how you can
run your functions in any
language as serverless code
on Google Cloud.
No matter if you're a Ruby,
.NET, Java, PHP, Python,
or Go developer, fear no more.
You can now seamlessly deploy
your function to Cloud Run.
In the last year,
the Serverless team
has been working to
support developers,
no matter which
language they use.
In fact, we have seven
plug-and-play libraries that
allow you to run your
code, in any language,
functions-as-a-service stat.
Last year, we launched Cloud
Run, a fully managed serverless
compute platform
based on Docker.
It automatically scales and
load balances your stateless
containers while language client
libraries automatically work.
You pay per request, so you
can do what matters most--
build great applications.
We've now open-sourced
a framework
that powers Google
Cloud functions,
called the Functions Framework.
It's a set of
open-source libraries
that minimizes the amount of
boilerplate and configuration
needed from you to create a
runable, stateless container.
In fact, this framework
is a dependency
that's used in Cloud functions.
So you'll get the
exact same core runtime
environment and behavior.
It handles-- setting
up a web server,
adding routing to the
server, and invoking
function code in response to an
HTTP request or a CloudEvent.
What this means
is you can simply
install the Functions
Framework library
for the language of your
choice and write a function.
You don't need to emulate your
function when testing locally.
Let's dive into each language.
The Node Functions Framework
uses Express.js under the hood,
adopts Node's event-based
model that's asynchronous,
has non-blocking
I/O, and supports
promises for handling requests,
and is an excellent choice
for scaling apps both
horizontally and vertically.
The Go Functions Framework
uses the native HTTP Package
for handling requests
and responses,
provides excellent
cross-platform support
and static type-checking
for your function.
And it's a great option for raw
performance and computation.
The Java Functions Framework
uses Java and Maven
for building and deploying
functions from source.
It's not limited
to Java, meaning
you can use different JVM
languages, such as Kotlin,
Groovy, and Scala.
You can use a Maven plugin and
run mvn function:run to run
locally and mvn
function:deploy to deploy.
And it's supported by
frameworks like Spring Cloud
Function and Micronaut.
For Python users, the
Function Framework
uses Flask, a popular Python
web framework, under the hood.
By default, it uses
Gunicorn as an HTTP server,
but also provides
a WSGI app so you
can use any HTTP server
that supports WSGI.
And it's installable
from PyPI with "pip
install functions-framework."
The Ruby Functions Framework
uses a standard Ruby Rack
interface for HTTP
requests and CloudEvents.
You can install your own bundle
and access all the libraries
and capabilities of
the Ruby ecosystem.
And it has built-in helpers
for building test fixtures
and invoking functions
in a test environment.
The .NET Functions Framework
is built on ASP.NET Core
in an idiomatic way,
incorporating familiar
dependency injection.
The templates are distributed
as NuGet packages.
Just use dotnet
new to get started.
And it includes a
dedicated testing package
so you can write unit and
integration tests easily.
The PHP Functions Framework
is usable with PHP's built-in
server, supports
symphony/http-foundation,
and will soon support PSR-7.
You can install
your own packages
and access all the libraries
and capabilities of the PHP
ecosystem.
Keep in mind, you are not
limited to these languages.
Any language that can be
run in a Docker container
can be deployed to Cloud Run.
Once you've built your
application with the Functions
Framework, Cloud Run
lets you get your code
into production in seconds.
Just run a gcloud command
to deploy your stateless
container, and Cloud
Run will do the rest.
Listen to requests and events,
pass them to your code,
and scale them up and
down to meet user demand.
With the Functions
Framework, you
can run your applications
as serverless code
in any language, port workloads
across any serverless platform
with an open-source
framework in Docker,
and spin up a local development
server for quick testing.
Check out cloud.google.com/run
to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]